the lifetime movie about Britney Spears
now the actress playing Brit is from
Australia but wait until you see the
boys playing in sync
[Applause]
[Music]
the flirting the NSYNC sort of
look-alikes Britney and Justin kissing
behind tour buses and secretly making
out inside them this lifetime movie has
guilty pleasure written all over it
he's happy oh my god actress Natasha
Bassett cried before filming this scene
which led to Britney's iconic yellow
Python dance at the 2001 VMAs and for
this scene the 24 year old used
prosthetics to give it a shaved head
look Brits 2007 melted everything's just
kind of this blurry what was that
process like for you it was really
horrible actually it was very sad and I
just feel like I have so much more of an
understanding of what she went through
now it's not like that you and me what
the 2-hour biopic addresses the rumoured
cheating that may have caused Brits
breakup with JT as well as her wedding
to Kevin Federline Britney herself has
not given her blessing to the production
it's really a love letter to her into
her story so I really hope she watches
it I wanna be
for my fans
I would choose me going
[Music]